AND APPEARED ON
STEPHEN COLBERT'S SHOW LAST
NIGHT.
WE'LL SHOW YOU THE WORST OF THE
WORST.
BUCKLE UP, TIME FOR AN IMPORTANT
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
TONIGHT, ONCE AGAIN, JOHN
SOLOMON HAS A MAJOR BREAKING
REPORT.
FUSION GPS LITERALLY
COMMUNICATED WITH OBAMA'S
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ALL AND LEAD
UP TO THE 2016 ELECTION.
REMEMBER, FUSION GPS WAS THE
CONSULTING FIRM, HIRED BY THE
DNC, AND THE COPTIC CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT DUG UP
THE DIRT ON THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP
THAT WAS FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES.
AND ACCORDING TO NOW NEWLY
HE KNEW ABOUT GLENN SIMPSON'S
EFFORT TO LEAK THE DIRTY DOSSIER
TO THE PRESS PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION.
HE WROTE, "IT WAS GLENN'S
HAIL MARY ATTEMPT."
HAIL MARY ATTEMPT, OF COURSE, TO
DEFEAT TRUMP WITH HILLARY'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
LIES.
GLENN SIMPSON GAVE HIM A MEMORY
STICK DURING A DISCRETE MEETING
AT A COFFEE SHOP.
BY THE WAY, WHERE IS THAT A
STICK?
IS AN ACID WASH?
TO THE BEAT IT UP WITH A HAMMER?
NOT PUT THIS SIMPLY, THIS NEW,
CLEAR EVIDENCE IS SHOWING
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN THE
OBAMA YEARS TO MALIGN AN
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE AND
BRUCE OHR, BARACK OBAMA'S NUMBER
AND AS WE SPEAK SOME OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN BOB
GOODLATTE, HE IS NOW
PREPARING SUBPOENAS FOR BRUCE
ABOUT CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND HIS
SHADY TIES TO A RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH.
BYRON YORK UNCOVERED EMAILS FROM
2016 SHOWING THAT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WAS IN FACT LOBBYING ON
BEHALF OF A RUSH OF ALUMINUM
TYCOON -- OH, GUESS WHAT,
WITH CLOSE TIES TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
ROBERT MUELLER, JEFF SESSIONS,
WHERE ARE YOU PEOPLE?
STEELE EVEN PRESSED BRUCE OHR TO
HELP RECTIFY THOSE RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS U.S. VISA STATUS AFTER
HE WAS ALREADY BANNED FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
AND STEELE EVEN PRESSED BRUCE
OHR TO HELP RECTIFY THE
OLIGARCH'S STATUS AND AFTER HE
SO HERE WHAT WE HAVE IS AN
EXCELLENT SPY WORKING FOR A
PUTIN-LIKE OLIGARCH, GETS HIM
INTO THE UNITED STATES AFTER
BEING BANNED, BY USING HIS
CONNECTION, THE NUMBER
FOUR GUY AT THE DOJ, DURING AN
ELECTION, WHERE STEELE, BEING
PAID BY HILLARY AND THE DNC,
THEY LITERALLY ARE USING RUSSIAN
LIES AND PROPAGANDA, THEY CREATE
THE OPPO RESEARCH AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, THEN YOU HAVE
FUSION GPS, THEN YOU HAVE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
DISSEMINATING THAT INFORMATION
TO INFLUENCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ROBERT MUELLER, YOU HAVE NO
INTEREST IN INVESTIGATING THIS?
YOU DON'T THINK THAT IS PART OF
YOUR MANDATE?
CAMPAIGN, RUSSIAN-TRUMP, OR THE
ELECTION?
THAT IS IN YOUR MANDATE?
THIS IS WHY MISTRAL, THAT'S WHY
THE PRESIDENT RIGHTLY IS
PROSECUTION OF A MAN THEY NEVER
WANTED TO BE PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE GOING TO STOP HIM.
AND AFTER EVERY DIRTY TRICK,
THAT THEY USED TO DEFEAT
WHY?
BECAUSE YOU VOTED FOR HIM.
I COULD GO ON AND ON BUT I THINK
RUDY GIULIANI SAID IT BEST LAST
NIGHT RIGHT HERE ON THIS
PROGRAM.
REAL STORY
HERE IS NOT THAT THIS CASE
ISN'T GOING TO FIZZLE, IT'S
WERE TALKING ABOUT BEFORE, THERE
IS A LOT MORE TO WHAT THEY DID
THAT NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT YET.
A LOT MORE TO THE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, TO THE COLLUSION, TO
THE FAKE DOSSIER, TRYING TO
BRING STEELE BACK IN AFTER HE
WAS COMPLETELY DISCREDITED.
>> Sean: AND THEN FEED IT TO
MUELLER.
>> AND MUELLER IS GOING TO HAVE
A LOT TO ANSWER FOR.
>> Sean: YES, HE DOES.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THIS WITCH HUNT
IS THE PINNACLE OF A TWO TIERED
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE ALIVE AND WELL
IN THIS COUNTRY, THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HILLARY CLINTON COMMITS
MULTIPLE, OBVIOUS, SERIOUS
FELONIES.
WE THOUGHT IT A MILLION TIMES,
MISHANDLING TOP-SECRET INTEL ON
A PRIVATE SERVER, DELETING IT,
ACID WASHING IT, BUSTING UP
DEVICES WITH HARD -- WITH
HAMMERS, OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE.
SHE GOT A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE
CARD FROM HER FRIENDS WHO WROTE
AN EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION, JAMES COMEY,
PETER STRZOK, AND OTHERS.
THEN WE HAVE SHIFTY ADAM SCHIFF.
REMEMBER, HE COLLUDED ON TAPE,
CONSPIRED ON TAPE WITH A RUSSIAN
TICKET DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
ROBERT MUELLER, WHERE ARE YOU?
MEANWHILE, PRESIDENT TRUMP, ALL
OF HIS ALLIES, THEY ARE SLAMMED
WITH THE FULL FORCE WITH EACH OF
FBI AND THE DOJ BASED ON WHAT IS
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES PUT TOGETHER BY A
SPY WHO IS FRIENDS WITH A
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH AND WORKING ON
HIS BEHALF TO GET HIM INTO THE
COUNTRY AFTER HE'S BEEN KICKED
OUT.
PAUL MANAFORT, OLD, BIG DECAYS,
TRIAL OF THE CENTURY.
FACING LIFE IN PRISON OVER A
WITH TRUMP, RUSSIA, OR THE
CAMPAIGN!
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN,
COERCED INTO A PLEA DEAL AFTER
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE WAS
WITHHELD, AND THEN HE HAS TO
SELL HIS HOUSE BECAUSE HE CAN'T
AFFORD TO PAY FOR HIS DEFENSE,
AND DON'T FORGET ABOUT EVEN
CARTER PAGE, 2016, THE FBI
THOUGHT HE WAS A RUSSIAN SPY.
AND WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY USED STEELE, FRIEND OF THE
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH, HIS DIRTY
DOSSIER, THAT EVEN HE DOESN'T
MISLEADING FOUR SEPARATE FISA
JUDGES TO SPY ON A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATES.
THIS IS ALL HAPPENING.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP IN A SPY
NOVEL.
BUT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP, WAS HE
EVER NOTIFIED BY OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT A POSSIBLE SPY
MIGHT HAVE INFILTRATED HIS
CAMPAIGN SO HE COULD HELP OUR
GOVERNMENT, HELP THE FBI?
NOT A CHANCE.
MEANWHILE, VERY DIFFERENT STORY
PLAYS OUT IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT,
BY THE NAME OF
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
LOOK AT THE SHOCKING
REVELATIONS, 2013, FEINSTEIN,
NOTIFIED BY THE FBI.
ONE OF HER TOP AIDE IS
INVESTIGATED AS A CHINESE SPY.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE FBI SOUGHT
TO PROTECT FEINSTEIN, NOT TRUMP.
PERHAPS BECAUSE THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE FBI ARE ROCKED
WITH ANTI-TRUMP CORRUPT BIAS AND
ARE TRYING TO TAKE DOWN THE
CANDIDATE, STOP HIM WITH AN
INSURANCE POLICY, IF, GOD
FORBID, HE DOES WIN.
NOT BENNETT DOMINIC
SENATOR FEINSTEIN.
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT ON THIS
PROGRAM, WE ARE BREAKING
IMPORTANT NEWS, INVESTIGATIVE RP
IMPORTANT NEWS, INVESTIGATIVE RR
IMPORTANT NEWS, INVESTIGATIVE RI
IMPORTANT NEWS, INVESTIGATIVE RG
IMPORTANT NEWS, INVESTIGATIVE R.
I HAVE SAID MANY TIMES, WE ARE
PEELING BACK THE LAYERS OF
CORRUPTION, THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER IN OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY,
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
NOW THAT IS NOT THE CASE AND THE
REST OF THE NEWS MEDIA.
LET'S TAKE, FOR EXAMPLE,
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC.
YOU ARE GOING TO LOVE THIS TAPE.
NOW THIS IS NOT THE CASE.
THEY ARE MORE INTERESTED IN
PUSHING SALACIOUS RUMORS, LIES,
ACCUSATIONS.
TOM BROKAW, YOU SPENT YOUR
ENTIRE CAREER.
THAN THEIR CHIEF CONSPIRACY
THEORIST RACHEL MADDOW.
LAST NIGHT, AFTER HER OLD
TRICKS, LITERALLY MAKING
SOMETHING OUT OF NOTHING.
WHIPPING THESE LEFT-WING VIEWERS
INTO A FRENZY OVER A SECRET
RECORDING OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES,
WHERE HE WARNED A ROOM FULL OF
DONORS THAT IF REPUBLICANS LOSE,
ALL DEEP STATE INVESTIGATIONS
WILL BE HALTED AND DEMOCRATS
WILL TRY TO IMPEACH TRUMP.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING THIS LITERALLY
EVERY NIGHT AND THIS
PROGRAM, THEY ALSO, BY THE
WAY, WANT OPEN BORDERS, TO
ELIMINATE I.C.E., KEEP
OF COURSE, MAKING A BIG DEAL OUT
OF NOTHING, THAT IS KIND OF
THEIR M.O. OVER THERE AT FAKE
NEWS MSNBC.
WE CAN'T FORGET ABOUT THEIR BIG
SCOOP.
REMEMBER, THEY GOT ONE PAGE OF
DONALD TRUMP'S 2005 TAX RETURN
FOR 45 MINUTES, WE GOT IT, HERE
IT IS -- HERE, AND WHAT DID WE
DISCOVER?
HE PAID MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS IN TAXES.
AGENT OF RUSSIA.
I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP.
WATCH.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT DID THAT
TODAY, BECAUSE HE HASN'T SOME
REASON TO SERVE THAT OTHER
COUNTRY, RATHER THAN OUR OWN,
BEEN INEXPLICABLE IS NOW
EXPLICABLE.
IS OUR PRESIDENT SUBORDINATE TO
A FOREIGN POWER?
DOES OUR PRESIDENT ANSWER TO A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT AND A FOREIGN
LEADER?
WORSE CASE SCENARIO IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS A FOREIGN AGENT
SUDDENLY.
NO MIKE FEELS VERY POSSIBLE.
WOULDN'T CHANGE THE WORLD AS IF
RUSSIA WAS INTERFERING IN THE
ELECTION AND THEY WEREN'T DOING
IT ON THEIR OWN, AND HE WAS IN
ON IT.
THIS GUYS SOMEONE WHO SUPPOSEDLY
WORKS AT THE RUSSIAN CENTRAL
BANK.
>> Sean: HE'S A FOREIGN AGENT.
NOW IF YOU THINK HER FAKE, OR
THEY ARE -- WELL, THINK AGAIN.
>> OF COURSE, TRUMP PICKED AS IT
AS A SECRETARY OF STATE NOT
TO WHOM VLADIMIR PUTIN HAD
PERSONALLY AWARDED THE RUSSIAN
ORDER OF FRIENDSHIP.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO TRUMP HAD
NEVER MET BEFORE THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, NEVER
HAD ANY DETAILS ON MY
DEALINGS WITH.
WHERE DID HE COME UP WITH THIS
AS A CHOICE FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE?
THE PERCEPTION THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAY HAVE ORDERED THESE
STRIKES IN PART BECAUSE OF
SCANDAL WILL AFFECT THE IMPACT
ON THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE
MILITARY STRIKES.
UNAVOIDABLY.
THEY PULLED THEIR TROOPS OUT
STARTING FRIDAY, SEPTEMBER 29TH.
THAT WOULD BE THE FRIDAY AFTER
BAFFLING DECISION TO INSULT ANDH
BAFFLING DECISION TO INSULT ANDR
BAFFLING DECISION TO INSULT ANDM
BAFFLING DECISION TO INSULT ANDO
BAFFLING DECISION TO INSULT ANDR
BAFFLING DECISION TO INSULT ANDC
BAFFLING DECISION TO INSULT ANDO
BAFFLING DECISION TO INSULT ANDE
THE TROOPS GOT PULLED OUT THE
29TH.
WELL, RIGHT AFTER THAT, THAT IS
WHEN FOUR U.S. ARMY SOLDIERS GOT
ATTACKED BY A LARGE CONTINGENT
BUY THIS BRAND-NEW FEC FILING
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
GET ANY WORSE, ANY MORE
DRAMATIC, ANY MORE
SELF-INVOLVED, YOU ARE
FORGETTING ABOUT CNN'S MOST
NOW HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE AN
CONTEMPT, HIS LEFT-WING AGENDA
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE HE
IS LAUNCHING HIMSELF INTO A
NATIONAL SPOTLIGHT.
HE'S BECOMING A STAR.
LAST NIGHT KEVIN I WOULD EXPECT
ON MIKE EXCEPTION.
HE TWEETED OUT THIS PICTURE OF
HIMSELF.
LOOK DEEPLY INTO HIS OWN EYES
JUST BEFORE APPEARING ON THE
"LATE SHOW" WITH FELLOW TRUMP
HATER STEPHEN COLBERT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THESE FOLKS ARE FOCUSED ON
THE COVERAGE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
BEHAVIOR MORE SO THAN THEY ARE
THE PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR.
NORSWORTHY THAN OUR COVERAGE.
BUT A LOT OF THESE FOLKS OUT
PRESIDENT'S BIDDING.
>> DO YOU WORRY THAT THE
PRESIDENT POINTS OUT Y'ALL SO
MUCH AND THERE IS A NATURAL NEED
TO RESPOND AS A HUMAN BEING THAT
YOU END UP BEING THE STORY WHEN
THAT IS NOT REALLY THE GOAL OF
YOUR JOURNALISM?
>> RIGHT.
WE ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE THE
STORY.
YOU KNOW, THAT IS NOT WHY I AM
OUT THERE.
I GET ACCUSED OF THAT FROM TIME
TO TIME AT MY ATTITUDE IS,
AS ANYBODY ELSE.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU ARE CORRUPT,
WHEN YOU LIKE ABOUT WHEN YOU'RE
NOTHING BUT AN EXTENSION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, YEAH, YOU'RE
GOING TO GET CALLED OUT.
BY THE WAY, THAT PICTURE WAS SO
BIZARRE.
AND ACOSTA'S CONSTANT FLIRTATION
WITH FAME OVER ACTUAL JOURNALISM
IS SO OBVIOUS THAT EVEN SOME OF
HIS PEERS IN A MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
THEY ARE BEGINNING TO NOTICE.
ON TUESDAY, "THE ATLANTIC"
REFERRED TO ACOSTA'S CONDUCT AS
A DANGEROUS BRAND OF PERFORMANCE
JOURNALISM.
MEANWHILE, FREQUENT GUEST ON
COMING OUT WITH A NEW
DOCUMENTARY.
HE REFERS TO TRUMP AS THE LAST
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A COUP.
IT'S GOING TO BE BAD.
A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
PRE-ELECTION LEFT-WING LUNACY.
>> HOW THE [BLEEP] DID THIS
HAPPEN?
>> THE AMERICAN DREAM IS DEAD.
ARE BEYOND QUESTION.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE
LAST PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WORST PICTURE YOU CAN FIND, ALL
THE SPECIAL EFFECTS.
PEOPLE OVER THE LEDGE.
SO, BY THE WAY, MICHAEL MOORE,
IF YOU ARE WATCHING, COVER YOUR
EYES, YOU ARE NOT GOING TO LIKE
WHAT I AM ABOUT TO SHOW.